Donald Trump blasts the fake news media
for ignoring Russia's uranium deal with
Clinton meanwhile the New York Times
alleges fake news ads are popping up
even on fact-checking websites and the
Democrats and John McCain but I repeat
myself are pushing legislation to
require more transparency on facebook
ads we'll discuss where the fake news
really lies then our cultural
correspondent Andy millennial joins to
discuss what the youth are keen on and
help to these days as well as the crisis
in the arts finally all of your problems
will be solved in the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Doyle show okay now away from the real
news now we have to get to fake news
there's fake news everywhere Trump
tweeted this morning the uranium deal to
Russia with Clinton helped and Obama
administration knowledge is the biggest
story that fake media doesn't want to
follow now this comes on the heels of
this week evidence emerged that the FBI
knew as early as 2009 that Russian
operatives were using bribes and dirty
tactics to shore up their atomic energy
footprint in the United States the Obama
administration approved the uranium deal
benefiting Moscow anyway
Hillary Clinton has been implicated in
this all the while let's not forget that
Muller the the special counsel who's
investigating Donald Trump he was FBI
director at the time this missus doesn't
look good for Democrats for the FBI
investigation or for the Russian
investigation rather and and and it only
looks good for fake news Democrats are
gearing up to battle the allegedly Pro
Trump fake news the New York Times
alleges that fake news has been in
hitting websites like Snopes and
PolitiFact
the alleged fact-checking web sites
Democrats are sponsoring legislation to
require Facebook ads to disclose who is
paying for them all of this misses the
point fake news is fake news the term
emerged when a left-wing college
professor but I beat myself again
circulated a Google document that listed
lots of right wing websites including
the Daily wire in the day
is after the 2016 election Democrats
accused all right wing websites of
propagating fake news the same
ridiculous smear that they used to tie
to the formerly only right-of-center
news outlet Fox News conservatives then
pouncing on the absurdity of this claim
pointed out the countless
unsubstantiated and outright false
smears against Donald Trump and
Republicans that mainstream outlets like
the TV networks CNN the New York Times
Washington Post breathlessly reported
CNN's now retracted Russia collusion
story which even forced them to fire a
team of reporters comes to mind another
example among countless examples the New
York Times ran a bombshell fake news
report headlined quote Trump campaign
aides had repeated contacts with Russian
intelligence even James Comey under oath
was forced to admit that this was not
true
now Donald Trump then masterfully
positioned himself to appropriate the
term it stuck to the New York Times and
it stuck to CNN in a way that it didn't
stick to us because the charge rings so
true the alleged epidemic of fake news
that John McCain and other Democrats
want to want new laws to address is
itself fake news another term for fake
news is propaganda that's the old term
propaganda is nothing new it's been
around forever it will remain a
communications tool as long as people
speak to one another President Trump has
narrowed in on the real issue the fake
news and media the issue isn't random
websites promoting partisan press
releases
it's the enormous institutional
behemoths like the mainstream media
which purport to present objective facts
without partisan slant often on public
Airways but in reality are simply shills
for Democrats and they attack
Republicans they're the fake news media
because they aren't news media they're
attack dogs for Democrats it's a subtle
distinction but an important one fake
news is fake news but the fake news
media are real adversarial and
conservatives ought to fight them tooth
and nail don't give them an inch okay
that's enough of the news that's all the
news I want to talk about a little bit
of fake news a lot of real news now we
have to bring on our one and only
cultural correspondent Andy millennial
entity thanks for being here sup
so Andy you're a millennial you're in
Holly
would all you kids all you're tweeting
about these days or the me to campaign
the Harvey Weinstein's sex scandal
you've been out here what have you
noticed well you know as a as a
millennial who identifies as a young
woman I came out here with my eyes full
of stars and you know these innocent
hopes and dreams and you know I
immediately ran into incredible
incredible sexual you know harassment I
was living with a couple of other young
girls and you know I suggested that we
all start taking showers together you
know for those who haven't been
following which you certainly should
Andrew Clavin and I have a new podcast
at together it's a narrative fiction
podcast called another Kingdom it's what
drew wrote so he did all the work and I
I've read it that and I will say
publicly for the first time Andrew
Clavin cast me in another Kingdom and
the casting process was it was a lot
like what you're reading in the papers
known as the Harvey Weinstein of the
podcast that's true I thought it was all
the Oscars and I thought no it's just
because I chase people around the world
the podcast has been a lot of fun and
people are responding to it shockingly
like it I mean it's it's I think it's
now it's all five-star reviews we're not
I'm not doing oh yeah I know I
I tried to they won't let me a bunch of
if you if you have listened by the way
even if you have it I don't really care
go over there and leave a five star
review it helps us out I'm definitely
subscribe on iTunes and be sure to
subscribe on iTunes stitcher Google Play
what I really like about this podcast is
that we couldn't have we couldn't have
had anyone make it for us no one would
have accepted this they wouldn't have
made
wouldn't publish the but there's no
there's no chance of it I mean I you
know I I've almost stopped pitching in
Hollywood because I just know it's gonna
get to a certain level and die and you
know I think I mean this this is not a
political story this is just a fantasy
is about a failed Hollywood screenwriter
one day walks through a door and he
finds himself in a bizarre fantasy land
and he's a murder suspect right in this
bizarre fantasy land we should say that
the second episode drops tomorrow yeah
because they're coming out once a week
so he's launched it on Friday October
13th and they'll be coming out every
Friday so we have the second episode
coming out tomorrow but the people might
be well people might be confused just on
this one bit I will never work in
Hollywood again and it barely works
before but you're a real Hollywood guy
you've had these big movies I had a very
good run of screen and by the way I was
dry I never all I ever wanted to do was
write stories like this is write novels
and fictional stories and I was dragged
into Hollywood and I was selling scripts
at a very quick pace you know they like
as most screenwriters will tell you they
weren't getting made right I was getting
paid for them and and a couple got made
and you know then I started to speak out
about politics and my phone stopped
ringing like that and now it's funny I
do get calls because they know I can do
certain things really well but I just
I'm just always suspicious that I'm
never going to get past a certain point
once they Google me exactly so because
it's not a partisan story it's not about
no Republicans right but it's a story
that just does not care about political
correctness it doesn't care about a lot
of the tropes that you find in
mainstream Hollywood and entertainment
if you're describing the world right you
want it to me this has always been true
there's no sense in sitting down at a
computer to write something if you're
not gonna try and tell the truth
so if you're just simply describing the
world you very quickly become
politically incorrect right because
girls are girls and men are men and we
want certain things we desire and you
know and you just can't describe that
world that's stay politically correct
and you're going to be honest and so I
would say that they might have gotten
past the first chapter on this maybe but
after that we're done the one bit there
is a transgender killer oh yeah the
trans
that would have knocked it right I would
have been right like stormed out of the
room no question and the thing is about
becoming a man to some degree I mean it
is a journey and it's a guy's a guy's
journey and I think that all that stuff
is just you just can't write about it
anymore honestly right and get into
mainstream show business which to be
honest with you I don't care I just want
to do what I do that is the really
liberating thing is every time I really
wanted to be in this movie or to get
this TV partisan my whole life staked on
it I was miserable and that and I and it
was hard to do and now I've got a ton of
opportunity as I get to make whatever I
want and it's a and there is a little
bit in this growing up narrative
Hollywood is Fantasyland it's where like
the craziest people in the world who
don't want to grow up move and work here
and you see that evolution with Austin
live the main character yeah even as
he's fighting off Eggers and nice right
because you do you know people do come
here with this idea they start out with
this idea they want to make art or they
wanted back they want to do all these
things and you wind up like you know in
toilet paper completely some working and
you know and all this stuff but that's
not really what you set out to do and
that and the town does turn you into
that I always tease my actors friends my
actor friends that they start out
studying Hamlet and they end up if
they're successful if they really make
it they end up shouting let the girl go
for the rest of their lives if you're
lucky if you look truly the top 1% of a
1% and there's that old showbiz line the
bet the guy who is shoveling out the
elephant cage you know he's mopping it
up and his buddy comes up to him says
don't you want to get another job and he
says what leaf show I know I I mean I
teased my pal
Nick Searcy the guy was unjustified yeah
I made that joke to him and he said that
literally like his first line in movies
or something get out of the car you know
that's what you wind up saying the rest
of you mix real art form is Twitter by
the way so Hollywood's falling apart we
get to do whatever we want and maybe
Hollywood will do something with it
maybe they don't maybe it's just a
podcast and people like it you're the
prophet of this conservative culture
sorely I am the Prophet it's really
weird there's no question you published
crisis in the arts a few years ago you
predicted a lot of what was happening
you
or rather you called for what's happened
yeah and then like I don't know like
Forrest Gump or something you end up
being in all the places that that's
happening is it is bizarre I mean I said
this to my wife like a couple of years
ago I said I keep going and making
speeches going we have to do this this
and this and then I noticed that I'm
doing it you know and it's it really is
weird because like I said I only wanted
to do one thing I have this very focused
I have the opposite of attention deficit
disorder once I'm focused on something
I'm totally and I only wanted to write
books I only wanted to write novels and
then I found myself between podcasts I
mean I helped invent an app that told
the ghost auntie Melissa oh he's you
know and one new one one more
yappy Award yes there's a best-seller
for a couple of weeks there and like you
know I didn't invent the technical part
of it I just wrote the script for my
friend Neil Edelstein but I mean it was
weird to be you know Neil pitched it to
me and I just thought I gotta do that
nobody's ever done that before you know
and then this stuff I did started doing
a PJTV and now I do it here these kind
of small but comical political
commentaries nobody was it was the first
of vision I know it's and now it's
everywhere my whole panel of deplorable
people who we're doing that generation
of people doing and I think look the
thing about it is is I looked I became a
conservative I was a liberal grew up a
liberal and I became a conservative when
I noticed that everything Ronald Reagan
said was going to happen happen and
everything they said about him turned
out to be untrue now you know you laugh
about that now but think about it for a
minute if suddenly you realized I don't
know some but saw everything like there
was no Washington DC it was a complete
construct of the media you go like wait
everything is a lot that was the
experience the experience was you know
when I saw the the Berlin wall collapsed
I felt like you got to be kidding me not
know two years after Reagan leaves
Austria the region said it would happen
and everybody said this idiot this fool
this cowboy this actor you know
oh I get it now you know he was right
they were wrong and and I think that I I
started to realize that there was an
entire I I called it the Empire of Lies
of this culture that was pushing stuff
on us that wasn't good for people wasn't
true it wasn't true that black people
were being helped by it wasn't true that
women were being helped I was all untrue
and so I started thinking well why
aren't the other people talking about
this and i rapidly found out it was
because conservatives as a group have
neglected the culture they don't care
about the culture they think the culture
Shakespeare and the Opera and they don't
think it's stranger things they don't
think it's what Netflix and all that
stuff it's Pinterest and of course
that's you know which is why you and I
kind of get Trump in a way yeah because
when he goes out against the NFL
that's where the culture is that's when
the reality TV star don't major reality
TV stars that absolutely that is that is
the culture so where's it headed well I
think I think what we I I say it like
this I you know when when we have the
Revolutionary War the British came over
the hill in ranks biggest Empire on
earth most powerful soldiers best
trained soldiers they have the guns they
have their thing and our guys were
popping up from behind rocks with like
flintlock pistols and popping them off
you know that's where we are right now
we're doing YouTube we're doing podcasts
we're doing you know we can I can write
my next novel if I want and just publish
it right online you make more money I
make more money yes as you would know
from major publication and like I feel
that we they are an empire of lies we
are this little band Gorillaz popping up
from behind the rocks and from behind
the trees and picking them off I think
we're gonna win yeah I mean I think it's
gonna be like you know it's gonna be
tough we're gonna have our Valley Forge
we're gonna have some tough times are
gonna come after us they always come
after us they have come after us I mean
they came after me they've done whatever
they can do to me you know but I think
it's great I think we're gonna beat them
and I think we are already beating them
and I think that Donald Trump is a sign
that we're beating them for all you know
I have problems with them for all the
things he does that I don't like he is a
sign that we can be heard even as
they're trying to drown us out whether
we can the
this one strong steady orange man and
stand up against the British Army
governor absolutely yeah I share your
hope entirely and it's great I'm not
sick and tired of winning winning
there's not too much wind bring on more
calf FA no question bring the calf Fe
all the way Andy millennial thanks for
being here great go go spread the
message to the kids you know we look
forward to hearing more on that teeny
bopper culture next time and another
Kingdom tomorrow episodes make sure you
tune in another Kingdom it's on iTunes
it's everywhere just search and reclaim
ins another Kingdom be sure to subscribe
be sure to leave a review and a 5-star
review and let us know what you think
about it too because we are we are just
little gorillas who are posting this up
so please send in your thoughts all
right Andy thanks for being here it's a
pleasure now I really want to enlighten
all of you I want to change your lives
I can answer every one of your questions
in the mailbag but I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube to all
of our current subscribers thank you
very much you helped keep the lights on
if FA and my mug but if you haven't
subscribed go over to the daily wire.com
it's $10 a month or $100 for an annual
membership you get me get the under
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
yeah yeah I know what else Michael what
else here it is
the leftist tears tumblr it is the
finest vessel for leftist tears in the
entire country
we have several vintages obviously that
it can hold its you know wine glasses
you need this for those strong red you
need this for the white wine you disco
you know this but it holds them all New
York Times Tears Hillary Clinton tears
Barack Obama tears be sure to go to the
daily wired.com right now you'll be able
to put them in there
hot or cold always salty and delicious
we'll be right back
now we have the mailbag we have a lot of
really in-depth questions this week so
let's get right to it
the first question from Alex Michael if
you could bare-knuckle boxing historical
figure who would you box and why good
question Alex I you know I'm a lover not
a fighter obviously that's why I always
have these all women panels of
deplorable z-- I don't want to fight too
much if I were forced to if I were
compelled to I would obviously want to
choose the weakest political opponent
that I power boxing opponent I possibly
could that historical figure would be
king charles ii of spain he was a
Habsburg king that was so deeply inbred
that he could barely function in any way
the physician who performed his autopsy
said that his body quote did not contain
a single drop of blood his heart was the
size of a peppercorn his lungs corroded
his intestines rotten and gangrenous he
had a single testicle black as coal and
his head was full of water
that is my boxing opponent it's gonna be
like Mayflower McGregor from honey hey
Michael I recently started caring about
the world rather than defaulting to the
left like many of my high school peers
and I found recently that I need to
educate myself about economics do you
have any recommendations for books that
to read that could give me an
understanding of the conservative view
of economics PS my name is pronounced
like Connie with an H that's what I des
what I said yes I do have a
recommendation especially if you're in
high school you should read Henry
hazlit's economics in one lesson there
are a lot of great intro econ books but
hazlit's is great it should be required
reading in every high school in this
country read it and you will be able to
debunk any nonsense that your high
school pals are trying to throw at you
from Jeffrey how much of success do you
attribute to having attractive females
on your panel so often listen yeah I'm a
taken guy okay I'm engaged to sweet
little ELISA but regardless I can assure
you I have had no success with the
beautiful women on my panel that date
that I had with roaming millennial that
ended the minute that Ben Shapiro
stopped playing violin no success at all
unfortunately what can you say that's
probably good it's good for my soul good
for my marriage that that might save my
save my spot in heaven someday from
Ashton hey yon brethren of philosophical
lucidity is the mere fact of newspapers
such as the New York Times endorsing
presidential candidates per se evidence
that they're biased cesspools of
distortion or should we as conservatives
offer more evidence to support our
claims
thanks Ashton I don't know that it's the
evidence that I would point to I have no
problem with newspaper editorial boards
endorsing political candidates the
trouble is what those editors make
terrible decisions about their reporting
so the I I don't really have a problem
with New York Times reporters I have a
problem with New York Times editors
because the editors decide which stories
go on the front page which go on page
3050 where the retractions go which
stories get covered which get buried
Cheryl Atkinson from CBS talks about
stories being buried because they were
critical of Obama so what I have a
problem with is we talked about earlier
in the show is news media pretending to
be objective arbiters of whatever
they're not they have a point of view an
editorial point of view they can try to
report the facts honestly but they
should they should be honest or they're
going to be fake news from Andrew why
does the Bible say quote I do not permit
a woman to teach or to have authority
over a man she must remain silent that
is from first Timothy 2:12 I don't know
man have you ever talked to them have
you ever tried talking oh I'm kidding
that's not true the reason it's in the
Bible is because someone put it in the
Bible but it is worth noting that first
Timothy and I think 2nd Timothy are
considered to be not actually written by
st. Paul so certain letters we know were
written by st. Paul or we have a very
good idea that they were there there's a
consensus right now that first Timothy
was not written by him the there were
306 words that Paul uses in his Paul
does not use in his unquestioned letters
that he does use there the style of
writing is different from that of the
unquestioned letters they reflect
conditions and a church organization
that apparently was not present in
Paul's day and they don't appear in
early lists of his canonical works so I
don't I don't really worry too much
about that now of course first
Corinthians 14:34
says something similar it says quote the
women should keep silence in the
churches for they are not permitted to
speak but should be subordinate as even
the law says one thing that's important
to point out here is that Paul is
talking to the Corinthians
unlike other major religions
Christianity is documenting things that
really happen it's not only talking
about the metaphysical it's talking
about the physical - it begins as
Christianity begins not in poetry but in
journalism tracking down what a guy did
with a bunch of other guys and how he
the divine logos of the universe became
flesh dwelt among us was killed and then
resurrected to redeem mankind so Paul's
talking to the Corinthians there seems
to have been an issue in the Corinthian
church about disorder in worship during
this time let's not forget st. Paul also
said there is neither male nor female
for a year all one in Christ Jesus
st. Thomas Aquinas said in the Summa
Theologica quote it was right for the
woman to be made from a rib of man first
to signify the social union of man and
woman for the woman should neither use
authority over man and so she was not
made from his head nor was it right for
her to be subject to man's contempt as
his slave and so she was not made from
his feet secondly for sacramental
signification for from the side of
Christ sleeping on the cross the
sacraments flowed namely blood and water
on which the church was established so I
wouldn't use either first Timothy or
first Corinthians as evidence that we
ought to treat women poorly or not let
them do anything st. Paul himself
actually alludes to women praying and
prophesying in the church but we should
base our views of the sexes and of
ourselves in our relation to God on the
text as a whole from Genesis all the way
all the way to the end from clay
greetings Michael if you weren't hosting
the Michael Noel's show what would you
be doing from clay that's a great
question I would probably be a vagabond
I would probably be begging for money
underneath the Queensboro Bridge what I
did before the Michael Noel's shown
before I published blank books is I'm an
actor so I was an actor in Hollywood in
New York and I also ran political
campaigns so it's
running campaigns and working on
campaigns in high school we had some
success in New York so I along with some
older political veterans founded a
little political consulting shop in New
York there aren't a lot of Republicans
out there so you know in the land of the
blind the one-eyed man is king we ran a
bunch of campaigns over there I'd
probably be doing that because politics
is show business for ugly people they
both have a lot in common they are
concerned with truth and with with
people they you have to like people to
do well at politics or in acting
certainly and in a lot of artistic
vocations so I'd probably be doing that
but this is a lot of fun too I guess
this is the combination of both of those
politics and show business right next
question from Andrew hey Michael big fan
of the show I was wondering what is the
best version of the Bible I personally
read the NIV but I know there's also the
kata the King James English standard
American Standard translations should I
read these two or should I stick with
mine also which do you read thanks a
million I do tend to favor the King
James Version I read the KJV a lot
another Catholic of me I guess I really
like it it's really beautiful I also
read the ESV I don't know a coin a Greek
but I have been told that the NIV is not
the best translation by people who do
read the Greek so I stick to those two I
think they're really good
my favorite translation probably of any
of them is the Jamaican New Testament
the jnt' I really suggest you look it up
you read it you google it it begins I
think the Gospel of John begins when
time did start the wood was weed good
and on and on and on so check it out a
great translation as well next question
from Benjamin hey Michael who's your
favorite senator and why my favorite
senator in recent memory is Tom Coburn
who I had the privilege of meeting him
once or twice he it's probably a sign of
the times that I can't name a sitting
senator that I would call my favorite
Coburn was great though he served three
terms in the House he served two terms
in the Senate he ended up having to
retire for health reasons but he said he
would not seek a third term anyway he
took a little break in between
in the Senate had a great career as a
medical doctor and in in the private
sector he was excellent fiscal
conservative and a social conservative
really just a model senator now he's at
the Manhattan Institute which is a great
thing tank as well the senator should be
more like Tom Coburn being more like Tom
Coburn and have some humility
Norris ISM is an occupational hazard of
politics but I thought he was a really
good one and our current senators who
are not being very productive should
follow his example the next question
from Emily Emily I'd appreciate your
opinion about whether or not to address
minor harassment from a person of
authority at work I'm the only woman on
a team of five this gender breakdown is
common in my field of Investment Banking
yeah that's a very masculine field
making it genuinely hard for me to tell
if the older man in question simply does
not know any better because of the work
environment he's experienced most of his
career there have been a few incidents -
standouts are the time you kissed my
cheek is a greeting it's not good in the
time he threatened to spank me when he
was exasperated about how much I was
challenging his work methodology that's
probably over the line now the spanking
probably crosses the line I'm reluctant
to involve HR because he's a genuinely
good character valuable asset to the
firm it's difficult for me to discuss
this issue with him because he views me
as a protege and has immense potential
to boost my career do you have any
advice about what I should do next
and what I should do the next time he
harasses me in an inappropriate manner
you're in a really tough spot Emily this
is not an easy question I think you've
honed in on it what do you do the next
time this happens it seems to me you
have three options you can either ignore
it and hope that you get an easier
career path as a result of it but then
the harassment might get worse you can
report it to HR that's a pretty that's
the probably the most extreme thing you
can do and then it's on the record so if
you suffer any repercussions for it it's
on the record and it's public and
everything or you can approach him
personally if you think he's a good guy
you have a good relationship with him
you can deal with him personally and the
worry here of course is that if he
responds badly to it and your
they're canned or you're not allowed to
be promoted at the right pace then
there's there's nothing on the record
then it's just he should he said she
said so I don't know I mean there are
consequences to all of them I think one
thing you people are looking for an easy
solution to to these I'm not saying you
are but in general people want these
difficult problems to have a simple
solution where there are no consequences
there are consequences a lot of times
people write in they say should I I'm a
conservative on a college campus should
I avoid
I've voiced my views and it's worked out
just fine for me I suppose but there
were consequences there were social
consequences even some academic
consequences to it that I had to deal
with his result those actresses in
Hollywood who said no to Harvey
Weinstein we've never heard of them for
a reason he did he killed their careers
you know and they had to deal with that
maybe they were braver for doing it now
everyone's jumping on the bandwagon and
pretending it's courageous it's not
courageous it was courageous to do it at
the time so I don't know if I were you
the safe answer is to go through HR I've
run this by a number of my friends this
question because it's it's pretty tough
but either the next time he does it you
can be very frank very forward that that
might be what I would do it in that case
but he what's really bad about what he's
doing is he's left you know good option
and if you if you want to play it safe
you should get it on the record but
again none of those are none of those
unpleasant and he's put you in a bad
position so anything you do is gonna
feel kind of gross unfortunately from
Theresa hey Michael how would you
respond to someone who claims that the
Catholic Church ordered the execution of
Jews during the Holocaust Theresa a
befuddlement I think is how out or it's
not there I that's absurd
the the Catholic Church saved hundreds
of thousands of Jews during the
Holocaust they did it through lobbying
the government they did it through
spying they did it through providing
false documents they did it through
hiding people in monasteries convents
schools with Catholic families and even
at the Vatican institutions that the
Vatican owned in the Apostolic Palace in
the castle Gandolfo
so I've actually never heard this that
the Catholic Church ordered the killing
of Jews if that's fake news out there
then let's try to dispel some confusion
the Israeli diplomat and historian
Pincus la pide I'm probably butchering
that name estimated the figure of Jews
who were saved by the Catholic Church
during the Holocaust is between 700,000
and 860,000 in the run-up to the war
both pope pius xi and Pope Pius the 12th
explicitly preached against racism and
war in papal encyclicals pope pius ii
worked secretly with his close confidant
father robert Lieber and dr. Joseph
Miller a catholic german lawyer who was
who the Nazis tried to assassinate he
worked closely with them to to spy on
the Nazis and to subvert their efforts
so he bugged rooms at the Apostolic
Palace when Nazis came around Hitler
actually threatened to kidnap the Pope
and to take him to Liechtenstein he said
quote I'll go right into the Vatican for
one thing the entire diplomatic corps
are in there we'll get that bunch of
swine out of there later we can make
apologies according to the SS commander
in Germany Karl Wolfe the plan was only
thwarted by the Allied liberation of
Italy this doesn't sound like a guy who
was collaborating with Hitler porta I
think where this stupid idea comes from
is there is a lot of revisionist history
one book in particular is called
Hitler's Pope by the revisionist john
corn well it's nonsense I mean it has
been debunked so thoroughly not only by
historical evidence we had at the time
but by new evidence that has emerged
since the the Second World War one
criticism that they make these
revisionists is that Pope Pius the 12th
didn't directly call out the Nazis or
address them this is sort of true
they're not really he actually did give
a Christmas speech about about the Nazis
but it's in part also because of keeping
innocents safe so at other times in
history when the church is spoken out
against rulers they've taken it out on
the on the persecuted so in part of us
to protect against innocence there is I
suppose atomistic concern from the
teaching of Thomas Aquinas and from
church teaching over regicide when the
the tyrant is not a usurper Hitler was a
tie
but he was elected democratically but
more practically and this has been
uncovered in documents Pope Pius the
12th was a pragmatist so he just wanted
his spies to be able to work more
clearly and it's a good thing he did
because they saved a lot of Jews who are
being persecuted in the process his
father George Rattler describes in his
excellent book principalities and powers
a lot of the heroes of that war a lot of
the great heroes the great Saints were
were Catholic clergy so I the stories
are endless I urge you to look that up
but that is just it's really awful
nonsense and I'm I'm not surprised that
forces that that great force is on the
move in the world that the
principalities and powers of this world
would try to spread such a horrific lie
from Andy Schwab Michael you seem to
really care for cigars what made you
think that I enjoyed seeing a nice
churchwarden on your return from England
do you also enjoy pipes if so what is
your favorite pipe shape and pipe
tobacco and do you prefer cigars over
pipes if so why I do prefer cigars over
pipes I much prefer cigars over pipes
mostly because I have trouble smoking
pipes it's hard to keep them laid you
got to tamp it and pack it it's it's
tough I do have a little collection of
pipes my favorite is in 1960s shel briar
by Dunhill and I also smoke a Dunhill
Museum I think also from the 60s or 70s
but I do it rarely it's a lot cheaper so
if you're looking to smoke and think and
sit by yourself it's a lot easier to to
maintain your habit of pipes rather than
cigars but cigars are more artistic it
requires someone to roll it to blend the
tobacco there's a lot more that can go
wrong and a lot more that can go right
about cigars there was also a good essay
written in first things about how
tobacco corresponds to the tripartite
soul so cigarettes are like the appetite
they're the pathos cigars or the
spirited part they're the ethos which I
certainly see you think of Churchill you
think of the smoke being pushed out to
that out of your mouth rather than
inhaled and the pipes are the logos the
it's feminine it's masculine it's the
philosopher smoking
look man I'm no philosopher so I don't
question it's unclear obviously cigar is
smoking cigars it's like eating a bunch
of vitamins and and working out you know
there
obviously excellent for your health I
don't think any real scientists will
question that but I do prefer cigars a
good question
Austin hey Michael big fan of the show
I've got two questions for you first who
is your favorite movie director second
if this director made a movie about your
life what actors would play you Andrew
Clavin and ben shapiro
thanks a lot of great directors i don't
know that i can really pick one I loved
John Ford I loved I loved Francis Ford
Coppola the Godfather is my favorite
movie
I really like the Coen brothers I you
know I I don't know it I couldn't pick
one director or producer team that I I
would would totally privilege over the
others other than maybe John Ford
because he's so so important for the
movie this is what we can end on today
for the movie version of the daily wire
or of my life who would play the
characters I think this is this is
pretty clear
Daniel Radcliffe would play Ben Shapiro
no question
Dwayne the rock Johnson would be Andrew
Clavin and for me it almost goes without
saying Denzel the similarities are
endless and in Denzel and I actually
have the same acting teacher 30 years
apart in New York okay that's our show I
can't wait for the movie to get made I'm
sure in the rubble of Hollywood someone
will be able to pitch it and get it
through I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show survive the weekend
check out another Kingdom on iTunes
wherever great narrative podcasts are
hosted and downloaded and we'll see you
Monday
[Music]
[Music]